and you're not in any creative process
at all i would never tell
anybody to outline your story except
there's two exceptions
creativity is a process not a
prescription
for product okay yeah i don't say you
know
here's the finished product let's work
to make the product and a product has
this it has that it is this it is that
that's what most writing classes
do uh matter of fact that's what most
literary criticism in the 19th century
did
and in the 20th century literary
criticism even
shifted to what what are the techniques
or the devices
that the author used not what is his
life about
and the freudian implications and the
social media of the time but
what are the devices that the artist
use to make that product well
i kind of go further back and go the
devices are something
that we write in in the process
toward product but we don't aim for the
finished product
we don't know where we're going to go
the creative
work is about the process working on the
concepts the exercises not on
a prescription for a finished product so
the concepts i teach in method writing
are not the end product they are the
process impulse so
all the concepts i teach not just in
level one and two
that we kind of talked about but in
level three four and five
and then the levels beyond i have a
whole bunch of levels um
it's it's about the process i'm
always wanting the artist to honor the
process
the way you work not what you're aiming
for
but just let the truth of the impulse of
your process
find its way and then when you finally
get your novel or your story
or your poem you won't have headed there
and my analogy in sports is in golf you
don't
aim you don't aim
to get the ball in the hole you hit the
ball correctly
you get the right club and you swing
correctly
and if you do that it'll go where it's
supposed to go
but you don't aim to put it in the hole
so you you go through your process and
let the end result
take care of itself so that's what i
mean when i say
the creativity is about the process
matter of fact isn't that the term they
use
they say the creative process
so if you come from the process
the product will emerge and it will
always surprise you
it will be unexpected you didn't expect
to be stuck
we started out with um
i'm really thinking about da da da and
by the time we got through going through
some of the techniques of
the other side of the coin and and other
things i
didn't bring up you end up being stuck
and writing about that subject that you
didn't expect to write about
so that's what i mean by it's
not a prescription for product it's a
it's a process do you
make sense it does do you see a lot of
writers that come in with the product
mindset
everybody ever you think everybody
starts out sure we're all human we all
have
you know ideas things we want to do
most people have some kind of idea what
they want to write about and they're
always surprised
that in some way they did do it
but they took a route they didn't expect
and if they had gone straight for it
it wouldn't have been what it ended up
being and that the
you know the unexpected path there
was what makes it interesting not
where they got why is it important to
outline the story before you start
writing it
it's not important i would never suggest
anybody do that
that's exactly what i just finished
talking about that's where you
you're looking at your product and and
you know
fitting your feet into the shoes of the
right size and you're not
in any creative process at all i would
never tell
anybody to outline your story except
there's two exceptions you would make an
outline of your story
if you're being paid
and this is the other component
because if you're just being paid and
this other component isn't there then
it doesn't apply you're being paid and
there's a deadline
tomorrow or at the end of the week
well okay they're paying me they want me
to write a story about ballistic
missiles
okay i'll do the best i can with my
talent
i'll outline what i need to do blah blah
blah i'll get it done in a week and i'll
make five thousand dollars
but if they're not paying me and there's
no deadline
why would i go with an outline for the
product
when the creative process is much richer
and holds so many unexpected marvels
that's what i want to bet on i want to
bet on that horse
the unexpected marvel that will come
from the unknown
and the unexpected of the creative
process
why would i do if no one's paying me and
there's no deadline
why would i purposely sabotage my genius
which doesn't come out all the time
anyway if ever
i'm not going to make an outline because
then i'm bound by the outline
so you don't need to know where you're
going when you when you're writing a
story
it's not about needing to know you are
better off if you don't know
if you know you're probably going to be
in trouble
it's like love
i'm not going to fill that blank tell me
i want to hear it
if you have a card and every time
with your date you keep looking at the
card already say something funny
okay you know it's it's got a list of
things you should do
that will make your date want you
i mean that's ridiculous you have to be
in the moment
and you have to just be there be in the
moment see what happens
love always happens when you don't
expect it to happen
right yeah that's true
that's true so you don't think blind
dates work
you what you don't think blind dates
work
if they're kept blind if you are open
a matter of fact i'm saying the opposite
i'm saying blind aches can work
listen to the stories that people tell
of how they met
you know people who've been together for
three four five years at least
i'll say you know i never expected that
he was my uncle's
uh neighbor and it was a wedding and he
was there and
and he's not anything like the person i
thought i would fall in love with
i thought it was going to be this this
and that and i don't know just something
happened and the next thing you know
we got five kids
you can't um oh there's a
is it the supreme you can't something
about love what is it
it's just very love can't what you can't
hurry love you you can't just
have to win sorry you don't want me to
sing
yeah no you don't want me to sing it
you i would be happy to hear you okay
all right but people we can we can put a
link to the video for the song yeah no
you know
if something is going to be written
written it's going to be written don't
be afraid
yeah you got that story about you when
you went fishing with your fight
it'll it'll come through don't don't
worry about it
go with the unknown and it'll come in
when you least expect it but go with the
unknown
that's the creative process
unless someone's paying you right and
there's a deadline
well you know you're not you're not
stupid
someone's gonna give me money to write
about ballistic missiles okay i'll do it
but otherwise i'm gonna go with the
unknown
so what about the people that say you
must have a road map for where you're
going
if not your story will not turn out and
i got a uranium mine that you must
invest in
uh somewhere out in nevada you give me
ten thousand dollars of your hard-earned
money
and i'll make you a million
what would you say to that can i go
visit the mine
i would say you take me on a tour i
would shut the door
so the same is true for the story you i
don't worry about it it'll come through
and anyone who says you must know your
story you might
if you want to put your money in a
uranium mine that's that's
your business but
you know it's not what i teach
so i'm not saying my way is the only way
but
it's what i teach
you